[Music]
no and then we got into how the original
message was not Chang okay so if it's
not the Bible what scripture did they
have that they were using to verify
Muhammad's
message I told you the
[Music]
Bible or your statement that the Bible
has authority over the Quran um you use
the verse in the Quran that says if
you're in doubt ask the people of the
book um this is referring
to the idea the message is consistent if
you are in doubt go ask the people of
the book and the the question was anyway
a rhetorical question because previously
it talks about the children of Israel
they differed after the message had come
to them and it tells the prophet if
you're in doubt go ask those that had
the scripture sent to them before it's a
rhetorical question intended for
reflection also it doesn't say go read
their books it said go ask them because
the message is consistent y this is the
message God has sent to humanity yes
absolutely so I don't understand then
how the Bible a book that was written
600 years after Jesus by a name a man
named Paul um who mixed in the the
Catholic the Catholic paganism you said
600 years yes the New Testament Paul
came Paul came 600 years after
Jesus he wrote I said so Paul wrote the
New Testament 600 years after
Jesus the Bible was written 600 years
after Jesus as it is today who who told
you that but I don't know the time
period you can Google it it's public but
regardless referring to the question
hold on I have I pull it up right here
it says that the Gospels were and the
writings of Paul were written in the
first
century not not 600 years after so who
told you that okay I found this online
but I can always go back and double
check let's go back to the I'm just I'm
just saying that whoever told you that
lied to you sis you got to be careful
okay okay let's go back to the original
statement about the of the Quan you had
misunderstood it was referring to the
message it was saying it was consistent
it's telling us to go ask the people of
the because if I ask you you'll tell me
there's only one God Jesus the Jews will
say the
same it doesn't tell us go read their
script do so yeah it does tell you to go
read their scriptures because it
literally says if you're doubting what
has been revealed to you go ask the
people who've been reading the scripture
before you so like you say like you're
you're you're right about it it talking
about consistency it's saying that
what's being revealed to Muhammad is
consistent with what was revealed before
him and the previous people uh can
verify that for him because they can
show it to
him We're very careful when we read the
Quran it doesn't say go read go look at
what was written for them it says go ask
the people not their scripture why would
he ask the people about the message
why it's a pondering question
uh yeah why look look hold on I
understand that it's hypo it's hypothe
not rhetorical but it's hypothetical it
says if if he doubts the Quran go ask
the people who've been reading the
scripture before him why if he's
doubting the Quran why is Allah telling
him to go ask the people who have the
previous scriptures
why he's not doubting the Quran I know
just a if just if I I I already said
that I said it's a hypothetical so
please let's focus on the actual
hypothetical here if if he's in doubt so
in the case that he is not saying that
he actually is just if Allah gives him
an instruction on what to do in the
scenario that he is in doubt of the
Quran okay yes which is to go and ask
the people who've been reading the
scripture before him why why go to
them okay that's a good question let's
say even for a regular Muslim if we're
in doubt this is the instruction that
applies to us if you're in doubt of the
message go ask the people the message
was the same and consistent not their
books all right stop wait stop there
stop there how will they know that their
message that the message of the Quran is
consistent with their message how would
they
know because as Muslims We Believe Islam
is not it didn't originate with Prophet
Muhammad God sent many prophets and he
sent many scriptures some of those we
still have though they have been mixed
in and so there are people that still
have the message
though um they you know changed it a
little bit so they have so they will be
using their scriptures to to see if
Muhammad's message lines up with their
message right because they have the
scripture the word let's not add the
word scripture because I'm not I'm not
I'm not adding I'm not adding the word
scripture literally the verse says go
ask the people who've been reading the
scripture before you I didn't add that
there the Quran says yes yes okay yes
and and so why so why I know so how will
they be able to know that Muhammad's
message and it's not even them Muhammad
himself too how will Muhammad and these
people verify that Muhammad's message is
the same as theirs how will they verify
that okay let's take me and you for
example as a Christian from your
knowledge if I ask you about the basic
tenants of Islam you'll agree with it
and this is the consistent message that
the Jews have and the people that came
why why would I why would I agree with
it because you have some truth in the
Bible That's why stop there right there
boom because it agrees with my Bible
right no because the Bible is a a lot of
different books and a lot of let let's
do it let's do it again you said you
said somale you said that I would agree
with the core Message of Islam
because it agrees with my Bible right
that's why I would agree with it
right no because when you say the Bible
it's very loaded as it's changed so you
know what let's let's be specific Torah
gospel Psalms that's what I have that's
what I believe in okay okay here's what
I'm why would I believe why would I
agree with The Message of Islam the core
message why would I agree with it
because it's in your Bible boom you just
did it again because it's in my Bible so
let me ask you this if the core Message
of Islam did not align up with the Bible
would I agree with The Message of
Islam um I don't think so no Mage from
God no wor no wores let's keep it slow
so we're we're building we're doing good
right now so okay if it lines up with
the Bible I will know that the Quran is
from God if it doesn't then I would know
that it's not from God and it doesn't
line up with the message that that's in
the scriptures so now let's let's
transfer this back to the Quran now the
people who read the scripture before
they're reading the Bible how what are
they going to be using to verify
Muhammad's message that his message yes
is good and it is from God what will
they be using to agree with
it okay at some point you included what
the Christians thought but really this
is about the Muslims confirming um the
message and the people reading the
scripture before Muhammad are
Muslims no no no this was a question for
the Muslims you said how do I know that
as a Christian if the Quran is correct
if I didn't rely on my Bible no let's
focus on the perspective the of the
Muslim first no I don't no that's what
it's about no but no we we already did
this we we we're coming from the
perspective of the Quran so all we did
was was plug in the characters in the
analogy okay let me give you the answer
you're looking for okay we believe we
believe the original in was sent from
God you changed many things but you
didn't change the main message got it
that that wasn't that's what I'm looking
for but so you're saying that they have
the scriptures that they're going to use
to verify what Muhammad is bringing
right not not the scripture the belief
asked the people not the scripture the
people where are they getting believe
from oh okay never mind let me go with
this then um you're saying that the
people change their scripture so is
their belief true is the belief that
they would have is that
true the main message yes but you know
how would how you're saying the main
message is true how would you know that
their main message is is true because if
I come to you as a Muslim let's say I
have some doubts about the Quran and I
rely on the previous scripture or
previous people whatever what and I ask
you let's say I I trust the people who
the previous scripture was sent to okay
and I'm a Muslim and I have doubts about
hey is the book consistent so I ask you
as a Christian why would you trust I ask
you okay I'm answering your question you
said let me answer your question do you
know what my question was I'm sorry do
you know what my question
was your question was that um how do I
know that you have the how do you know
that you have the same message as Islam
no that wasn't my question my question I
I'll do it again my you said that oh no
they changed their scripture so it's
their belief their belief is what what
what they're going to be using my
question was how do you know that their
belief is correct is true how do they
know what what is their belief being
based
on and I gave you an example I was
saying assume I trust the Christian I
don't care about trusting the Christian
where does their belief come
from okay you ask me another question
now it's been the same one go back to
the previous one no it's not because you
keep interrupting me when I'm trying to
give you an example I'm only
interrupting you because you're going
off and you're saying you're answering
my question by not answering my question
you're not dealing with the question I
asked
you okay what was your question do it
again here's the third
time what is their belief based
on the people who' been the people
who've been reading the scripture before
what is their belief based
on uh the message from the prophets that
they had received and where are
those I told you the original message is
in the Bible but you changed a lot of
other information okay so let's let's
just be let's be as honest as we can and
let's be honest with the text and say
that that and we know hold on hold on
let's be honest and let's not play with
this we know that they have the Bible
that they're relying on that's what the
that's what they're using to see whether
or not the message Muhammad is coming
with lines up with theirs they're using
they're comparing it with the Bible
right um the Christians are doing it
we're not looking at the Bible we're not
instructed to look at the Bible but
Muhammad is Muhammad is told to go look
at he literally says if you're doubting
the Quran go ask the people who've been
reading the scripture before
you yes so so if M if Muhammad's
doubting not saying he is but
hypothetically if Muhammad is doubting
the
Quran he's supposed to go check with the
people who have the scripture that came
before him to see it okay there's no
there's nothing wrong with that that's
actually the right thing to do here's my
point though my point is the fact that
he has to do that to clar to clarify
doubts that he would have in that
scenario means that the previous
scripture is the authority over the
Quran not the other way around again
again you're trying to put in your
scripture in places where it's
irrelevant it's not talking about your
scripture in this case it's a rhetorical
question has any doubt about this
message it's not the quranic verses
about this message go confirm it with
the people of the book they they had the
same message consistently and you said
you know where do you get your
information in your message if it's not
your scripture I didn't ask where you
get yours no I let's no no you as me you
asked me where the Christians get their
message and you said the Bible no I
didn't I was just responding when you do
you want me to rewind the tape because I
have it you want me to rewind it no and
then we got into how the original
message was not Chang okay so if it's
not the Bible what scripture did they
have that they were using to verify
Muhammad's message
I told you the Bible that was corrup oh
my
God you're looking for things that are
not in the verse
[Music]
[Applause]
as a Muslim we don't use our brain If
Allah contct our brain we take our brain
out of the sight
[Music]
h
Muhammed was right
[Music]